This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Do you want to know what it is? The Matrix is everywhere. It is all around us. In the hit 1999 sci-fi film The Matrix, the character Morpheus, played by Lawrence Fishburn, tells Keanu Reeves' character Neo about the hidden forces that control the world. Worn into a prison that you cannot smell or taste or touch. A prison for your mind. Morpheus offers to let Neo see the truth for himself.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。你想知道那是什么吗？母体无处不在。它就在我们周围。在1999年的热门科幻电影《黑客帝国》中，劳伦斯·菲什伯恩饰演的墨菲斯告诉基努·里维斯饰演的尼奥，那些控制世界的隐藏力量。它是一个你无法闻到、尝到或触碰的监狱。一个囚禁你思想的监狱。墨菲斯提出让尼奥亲眼看看真相。
But to do so, he first needs to make a choice. Morpheus shows Neo his closed fists. You have to see it for yourself. He opens his palms one by one. In his left hand is a blue pill. In his right, a red pill. He asks Niel to choose. This is your last chance. After this, there is no turning back. You take the blue pill. The story ends. You wake up in your bed and believe whatever you want to believe. You take the Redville, you stay in Wonderland, and I show you how deep the rabbit hole goes.
但要做到这一点，他首先需要做出选择。墨菲斯向尼奥展示了他紧握的双拳。你必须亲眼看看。他一个接一个地张开手掌。左手里是一颗蓝色药丸。右手里是一颗红色药丸。他让尼奥选择。这是你最后的机会。此后，就没有回头路了。你吃了蓝色药丸，故事结束。你在床上醒来，相信你想相信的一切。你吃了红色药丸，你留在仙境，我会让你看看兔子洞到底有多深。
All of us confront forks in the road. They might be less permanent and irreversible than the one confronting Neo, but then again, the choices we confront in real life are real. Should we move to another city or stay put? Say yes to a marriage proposal or say no. Re-invent a business or stick to doing what we know best. This week on Hidden Brain, the psychology of dilemmas and how to learn to make better choices.
我们所有人都面临着人生的十字路口。它们可能不像尼奥面临的那样永久且不可逆转，但话说回来，我们在现实生活中面临的选择是真实的。我们应该搬到另一个城市还是留在原地？接受求婚还是拒绝？重塑业务还是坚持做我们最擅长的事？本周在《隐藏的大脑》中，我们将探讨困境的心理学，以及如何学会做出更好的选择。
Sometime in the recent past, you have probably wrestled with a dilemma like this. Should you miss your vacation in order to attend your cousin's wedding? Or maybe you've debated whether to make a risky investment? Or perhaps you're asking yourself right now, should you work less to spend more time with your child? To confront the dilemma is to feel pulled in two directions. We sense that no matter which course we choose, we are going to lose something important. Wendy Smith is a psychologist at the University of Delaware. She studies leadership and organizational behavior. She also studies how we think about dilemmas and how we ought to think about them. Wendy Smith
在不久前的过去，你可能也曾纠结于这样的困境。你应该错过假期去参加表亲的婚礼吗？或者你可能曾争论过是否要进行一项有风险的投资？又或者你现在正在问自己，我应该少工作一点，多花时间陪孩子吗？面对困境就是感到被拉向两个方向。我们感觉到，无论我们选择哪条路，我们都会失去一些重要的东西。温迪·史密斯是特拉华大学的心理学家。她研究领导力和组织行为。她也研究我们如何思考困境，以及我们应该如何思考它们。温迪·史密斯。
welcome to Hidden Brain. Shankar it's great to be here. Wendy I'd like to start by hearing the story of a man you've studied, he was an American scientist named Edwin Land, and something important happened when he went on a vacation in 1943 with his family. Tell me that story. Well Land was a scientist who was at Harvard, and he left Harvard before graduating to start the company of Polaroid and he was making polarized filters for cameras and sunglasses and one day when he was on vacation he took
欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。尚卡尔，很高兴来到这里。温迪，我想从你研究过的一个人的故事开始，他是一位名叫埃德温·兰德的美国科学家，1943年他和家人去度假时发生了一件重要的事情。讲讲那个故事吧。嗯，兰德是一位在哈佛大学的科学家，他在毕业前就离开了哈佛，创办了宝丽来公司，他当时正在为相机和太阳镜制造偏振滤光片，有一天他在度假时，他用相机拍了
a picture of his daughter Jennifer with a camera and she wanted to see that picture immediately. And this question was the spark for him to develop the instant camera, what we now know as the Polaroid camera, to develop instant film. And it really captured the market. They were the market leaders. So that by the end of the 1970s, they were pulling in more than a billion dollars annually in sales. Polaroid wasn't just a business success. It became a cultural phenomenon. Famous Americans would carry Polaroid cameras around with them, snapping pictures of their
一张他女儿詹妮弗的照片，她想立刻看到那张照片。这个问题成为了他开发即时相机，也就是我们现在所知的宝丽来相机的火花，去开发即时胶片。它确实占领了市场。他们是市场领导者。到1970年代末，他们的年销售额已超过10亿美元。宝丽来不仅仅是一个商业上的成功。它成为了一种文化现象。著名的美国人会随身携带宝丽来相机，拍摄他们的
lives just like Instagram influencers today. It says yes, taking the shot, counting down, dimming it off, painting. The company was seen as hip and cool. It was also a pioneer in developing a stunningly successful business model. Today, we call it the Razer and Blade Model. This became really important to their success and how they thought about the organization and the business. So the Razer and Blade model essentially is that companies sell the Razor's cheap and
生活，就像今天的Instagram网红一样。它说“是的，拍照，倒计时，吐出照片，显影”。该公司被视为时髦和酷的代名词。它也是开发出令人惊叹的成功商业模式的先驱。今天，我们称之为“剃须刀与刀片模式”。这对于他们的成功以及他们如何思考组织和业务变得非常重要。所以“剃须刀与刀片模式”本质上就是公司廉价出售剃须刀，
then make money on the blades of the cartridges. It's the same model that companies use for printers and ink. For Polaroid, they essentially figured out that if they sold their cameras cheap, they could then get the cameras into the hands of lots of people and the people would therefore need more film to use for those cameras. So they would sell their cameras in places like Kmart and Woolworth's, not in specialty camera stores, and it created a tremendous market for their film, which they would make as much as 70% profit just on the film.
然后通过刀片或墨盒赚钱。这与公司用于打印机和墨水的模式相同。对于宝丽来来说，他们基本上发现，如果他们廉价出售相机，他们就能让相机进入许多人的手中，而人们因此需要更多的胶片来使用这些相机。所以他们会在凯马特和伍尔沃斯这样的地方销售相机，而不是在专业的相机店，这为他们的胶片创造了巨大的市场，他们仅在胶片上就能获得高达70%的利润。
Polaroid didn't think of itself as an instant camera company, it thought of itself as an instant film company. In its heyday, it boasted a workforce of more than 20,000 people and had a 75% market share. Best of all, Edwin Land and the company he had built didn't just sit back on their laurels. Polaroid devoted enormous sums of money to research and development in order to maintain that domination of the instant photo business. This position in the marketplace is no accident.
宝丽来并不认为自己是一家即时相机公司，它认为自己是一家即时胶片公司。在鼎盛时期，它拥有超过2万名员工，市场份额高达75%。最棒的是，埃德温·兰德和他建立的公司并没有躺在功劳簿上。宝丽来投入了巨额资金用于研发，以保持在即时摄影业务中的统治地位。这种市场地位绝非偶然。
It has been carefully built and owes its growth to a good many factors. Constantly improved. So the company was started by a land who was a scientist. His main focus was engineering. The company was really focused on being an engineering company. It was strong in their DNA and in their culture. They had very much then not invented here syndrome, which was that they weren't going to buy technology
它是精心构建的，其增长归功于许多因素。不断改进。所以这家公司是由一位科学家兰德创立的。他的主要重点是工程。公司确实专注于成为一家工程公司。这在他们的基因和文化中根深蒂固。他们当时非常有“非我所创”综合症，也就是说他们不会购买公司外部的技术
and innovation from outside the company. They really were going to invest and figure out how to create new things inside the company. So this is a real success story. Someone who comes up with a brilliant idea sees a need in the market. Engineers a device that basically millions of people find really useful captures enormous market share and makes huge profits, I mean, incredible success story. But then along come the 1980s, and then there's another innovation
和创新。他们确实打算投资并弄清楚如何在公司内部创造新事物。所以这是一个真正的成功故事。有人提出了一个绝妙的想法，看到了市场需求。设计了一种数百万人都觉得非常有用的设备，占据了巨大的市场份额并获得了巨额利润，我的意思是，这是一个令人难以置信的成功故事。但随后到了1980年代，又出现了另一项创新
in the world of photography. Tell us what happens next, Wendy. Right, and so Polarid's story is like so many stories we've seen of large companies where a new technological innovation comes up and it's the large companies, the sort of big oil tankers out there, that have the hardest time shifting and turning,
在摄影界。告诉我们接下来发生了什么，温迪。好的，宝丽来的故事就像我们看到的许多大公司的故事一样，当一项新的技术创新出现时，正是那些大公司，那些像大油轮一样的公司，最难转向和改变，
compared with the small and entrepreneurial organizations. In this case, it was digital photography, digital imaging, in which it was no longer the analog picture that got placed onto the film. It was digital pictures, the kind that we now take on our phones all the time. And did Polaroid see the danger? Did they say this might be a market we might want to invest in it as well? They did actually, they were engineers. This was an engineering company through and through. And so they did see the possibility. They were excited about the technology of digital imaging. In fact, in the 1980s, they had invested something like 30 million dollars of capital investment to develop a microelectronics lab with an annual $10 million budget in order to explore how to develop this digital imaging.
与小型和创业型组织相比。在这种情况下，它是数码摄影，数字成像，不再是将模拟照片放在胶片上。它是数字照片，也就是我们现在在手机上一直拍摄的那种。宝丽来看到危险了吗？他们是否说这可能是一个我们也想投资的市场？他们确实看到了，他们是工程师。这是一家彻头彻尾的工程公司。所以他们确实看到了可能性。他们对数字成像技术感到兴奋。事实上，在1980年代，他们投入了大约3000万美元的资本投资，建立了一个微电子实验室，每年有1000万美元的预算，以探索如何开发这种数字成像。
So if you were to tell me the story at this point and stopped here, and you say, you know, this is a company that has, in some ways, the best position in terms of photography, in terms of capturing a huge share of the existing market. There are science and R&D company. They've invested and figured out ways to actually build digital cameras. I would say this company is perfectly poised to capture this next wave of the photography market. Is that what happened?
所以如果你现在把这个故事讲给我听，讲到这里停下来，你说，你知道，这是一家在摄影方面，在占据现有市场巨大份额方面，在某些方面处于最佳位置的公司。他们是一家科学和研发公司。他们已经投资并找到了实际制造数码相机的方法。我会说这家公司完全有能力抓住摄影市场的下一波浪潮。这就是发生的事情吗？
Well, that would be a good hypothesis and that is absolutely not what happened to Polaroid. In fact, rather than capturing the market, they got stuck in their existing strategy. They had this razor and blade business model. You sell the razor cheap, make money on the blade. You sell the camera cheap cheap make money on the blade, you sell the camera cheap make money on the film. The problem was was that when it comes to digital imaging, there is no film. And so they kept going back and trying to figure out how you printed out these digital images. What was the value of being able to print this? Thinking that indeed their customers, just like
嗯，那会是一个很好的假设，但这绝对不是宝丽来发生的事情。事实上，他们没有抓住市场，而是陷入了现有的战略中。他们有这种“剃须刀与刀片”的商业模式。你廉价出售剃须刀，通过刀片赚钱。你廉价出售相机，通过胶片赚钱。问题在于，当涉及到数字成像时，没有胶片。所以他们不断回头，试图弄清楚你如何打印出这些数字图像。能够打印出这些照片的价值是什么？认为确实他们的客户，就像
Lann's daughter Jennifer, would want the hard copy of the picture in their hands immediately, and yet not thinking through or realizing that as the technology would move forward, so too with the market in terms of how we would all think about photography and pictures and images. What about the profit margins on cameras versus film? Did that play a role in their thinking? Right, so if they were making such a large profit on their film, why go back to something smaller on digital cameras?
兰德的女儿詹妮弗一样，会想要立刻拿到照片的硬拷贝，却没能深思熟虑或意识到，随着技术的发展，市场也会随之改变，我们所有人对摄影、照片和图像的看法也会改变。那么相机与胶片的利润率呢？这在他们的思考中起作用了吗？是的，如果他们在胶片上获得了如此巨大的利润，为什么要回到数码相机上利润更少的东西呢？
Our colleague, Mary Tripsis, who did a deep dive into this work on Polaroid and their transition or what she says, what was fascinating to me was that these guys used to turn their noses up at 38% margins on digital cameras. That was their big argument. Why 38% when they can get 70% on the film? Why would they wanna do this?
我们的同事玛丽·特里普西斯对宝丽来及其转型进行了深入研究，或者她说，让我着迷的是，这些人过去对数码相机38%的利润率嗤之以鼻。那是他们最大的论点。当他们在胶片上能获得70%的利润时，为什么要满足于38%？他们为什么要这样做？
Yeah, so they were like, we are making money hand of a fist year, we're basically printing money here with our instant film. Why would we want to get only a 38% profit by selling digital cameras? That's right. So tell me the rest of the story. What happened to Polaroid as the market eventually evolved
是的，所以他们就像是，我们现在赚得盆满钵满，我们基本上是在用我们的即时胶片印钞票。我们为什么要通过销售数码相机只获得38%的利润呢？没错。所以告诉我故事的其余部分。随着市场最终向数码相机演变，宝丽来发生了什么，温迪？
towards digital cameras, Wendy? Well, eventually they realized that they have to create a digital camera. And so they did introduce their digital camera in 1996. But by that point, they were way behind the curve. There were more than 40 competitors in the marketplace. Their new CEO, Gary Di Camillo, came in and talked about how challenging this was because he was, as he said, quote, trying to change the fan belt on the car while the engine is running. ban belt on the car while the engine is running, but eventually wasn't able to get into the market. And eventually, Polaroid had to file for bankruptcy.
嗯，最终他们意识到他们必须制造数码相机。所以他们在1996年推出了他们的数码相机。但到那时，他们已经远远落后于时代了。市场上已经有40多家竞争对手。他们的新任首席执行官加里·迪卡米洛上任后谈到了这有多么困难，因为正如他所说，引用，“试图在引擎运转时更换汽车的风扇皮带”。在引擎运转时更换风扇皮带，但最终没能进入市场。最终，宝丽来不得不申请破产。
The news has been all bad all year for Polaroid. Layoffs, defaults on his bond payments, cuts in benefits, and rumors the company will sell its distinctive headquarters building to help pay $940 million in debt. In fact, I remember this moment. It was in 2001. I was in grad school at the time. Polaroids offices were right across the river from my office. And I saw the headquarters going from a somewhat bustling
宝丽来的消息全年都很糟糕。裁员、债券违约、削减福利，以及有传言称该公司将出售其独特的总部大楼以帮助偿还9.4亿美元的债务。事实上，我记得那一刻。那是在2001年。我当时正在读研究生。宝丽来的办公室就在我办公室的河对岸。我看到总部从一个相当繁忙的
place to up for sale. It seems perverse that a company with all the resources and know-how of Polaroid, a company that had been heralded for its innovations, failed to capitalize on its advantages. Yet Wendy has found that this is not unusual. She argues that Polaroid's downfall is connected to a larger problem in the way many of us confront dilemmas. That's right. We see this happen again and again market leaders committed to their existing worlds are the ones that are at the greatest peril for failure.
地方变成了待售。一家拥有宝丽来所有资源和技术诀窍的公司，一家因其创新而受到赞誉的公司，却未能利用其优势，这似乎很反常。然而温迪发现这并不罕见。她认为宝丽来的倒闭与我们许多人面对困境的方式中的一个更大的问题有关。没错。我们一次又一次地看到这种情况发生，致力于现有世界的市场领导者是那些最容易失败的人。
The greatest indicator of failure is success because it's so hard to transition from the existing world into the new world. And the underlying problem here is not just that they can't transition, but they are stuck in binary either or thinking between either focusing on the way that they've always done things in their existing world, or into the ways that they're going to move into the future, they can't live in both at the same time. Whether we are executives managing a multinational cooperation or individuals navigating our personal lives, all of us are presented with a constant stream of dilemmas. They pull us first in one direction and then in another. To solve these dilemmas, we often ask ourselves the question, which path is best?
失败的最大指标就是成功，因为从现有世界过渡到新世界太难了。这里潜在的问题不仅是他们无法过渡，而是他们陷入了二元对立的“非此即彼”思维，要么专注于他们一直以来的做事方式，要么专注于他们将要进入未来的方式，他们无法同时生活在两者之中。无论我们是管理跨国公司的高管，还是在个人生活中摸索的个人，我们所有人都面临着不断的困境。它们先是把我们拉向一个方向，然后又拉向另一个方向。为了解决这些困境，我们经常问自己一个问题，哪条路最好？
We might draw up a list of pros and cons, but it turns out this seemingly reasonable way to frame the problem conceals a trap. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Psychologist Wendy Smith studies the way we think about dilemmas. When we are faced with a choice, we often feel we have to go in one direction or another. Wendy, you argue there is something fundamentally wrong with that binary approach that either or thinking. What is wrong with it?
我们可能会列出利弊清单，但事实证明，这种看似合理的框架问题的方式隐藏了一个陷阱。你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。心理学家温迪·史密斯研究我们思考困境的方式。当我们面临选择时，我们经常觉得必须走一个方向或另一个方向。温迪，你认为那种二元方法，那种“非此即彼”的思维，在根本上是有问题的。它有什么问题？
Yeah, we say that either or thinking is limited at best and detrimental at worse. And the reason is, is because it leads us down these vicious cycles. We either get stuck in one way of thinking and not seeing the whole and bigger picture, it minimizes the potential for engaging other perspectives that can let us be much more creative. And it can create an ongoing loop of negative conflict that just creates this downward cycle, this downward race to the bottom. So I'd like to look at these problems in some detail, but I want to first ask the question, why are minds gravitate so readily to this binary model? Why is that
是的，我们说“非此即彼”的思维充其量是有限的，往坏了说是极其有害的。原因在于，它引导我们陷入这些恶性循环。我们要么陷入一种思维方式，看不到整体和更大的图景，它最小化了参与其他视角的潜力，而这些视角可以让我们更有创造力。它还会造成一种持续的负面冲突循环，从而产生这种向下的螺旋，这种向下的逐底竞争。所以我很想详细看看这些问题，但我首先想问一个问题，为什么我们的思想如此容易倾向于这种二元模型？为什么会这样，
windy? Yeah, and I think it's both how we think about things and how we behave. So the way that we think about issues, we like to anecdotally break issues down into opposing sides, split them apart, and in doing that, we then want to make a choice. Because emotionally, if we leave the choice open, it makes us feel more anxious. We feel a little bit more fear in the uncertainty, so the more quickly we can make a choice, the more that we can engage and feel more connected. And then behaviorally, the things that are around us, once we've made a choice, we kind of get into a habit of reinforcing that choice so that we can maintain a commitment to
温迪？是的，我认为这既关乎我们如何思考事物，也关乎我们如何行事。所以我们思考问题的方式，我们喜欢把问题轶事化地分解成对立的双方，把它们分开，在这样做的时候，我们然后想要做出选择。因为在情感上，如果我们让选择保持开放，它会让我们感到更焦虑。我们在不确定性中感到一点恐惧，所以我们做出选择的速度越快，我们就越能参与其中并感到更紧密。然后在行为上，我们周围的事物，一旦我们做出了选择，我们就会养成强化该选择的习惯，以便我们可以保持对
the way that we've always done things. So what I hear you saying, Wendy, is that even though dilemmas can feel painful, in some ways they're an example of simplified thinking. In some ways, we're simplifying the world by presenting it to ourselves as an either-or choice. That's right. And being able to make that choice makes us feel more comfortable. So as soon as we frame a dilemma as an either-or choice, your research has found that there's a cascade of mental and emotional consequences that follow. And the first is that we feel powerful pressure
我们一直以来的做事方式的承诺。所以我听到你说的，温迪，是即使困境可能让人感到痛苦，在某些方面它们是简化思维的一个例子。在某些方面，我们通过将世界呈现为“非此即彼”的选择来简化它。没错。而且能够做出那个选择让我们感到更舒服。所以一旦我们将困境框架为“非此即彼”的选择，你的研究发现，随之而来的是一系列心理和情感后果。首先就是我们感到强大的压力
to make a choice. Can you walk me through how this works? So imagine what we do to college students, just as they're about to graduate. We say to them, what are you gonna do next? Or what we do when we have an open question. For example, if we think about the pandemic, there were all kinds of open questions
去做出选择。你能带我了解一下这是如何运作的吗？所以想象一下我们对大学生做了什么，就在他们即将毕业时。我们对他们说，你接下来要做什么？或者当我们有一个开放性问题时我们做了什么。例如，如果我们思考大流行，有各种各样的开放性问题
and people just wanted those questions to be answered. We don't want to leave them open. And so there is this both internal pressure to try and make a choice to minimize the discomfort. There's also this external pressure of looking for some clarity and some decisiveness. So once we do land on one side or the other of this, you know, either our binary, other cognitive mechanisms get set into motion, can you talk about how making a choice can lead us in some ways to become invested in that choice? Yeah, so one of the pieces that happens is that we have this pressure to be consistent, both to be consistent in our choice and to be consistent over time. That is we get
人们只是想让这些问题得到回答。我们不想让它们保持开放。所以既有试图做出选择以最小化不适的内部压力。也有寻求某种清晰度和果断性的外部压力。所以一旦我们确实落在了这个，你知道，二元对立的某一边，其他认知机制就会启动，你能谈谈做出选择如何以某种方式导致我们对该选择进行投入吗？是的，发生的事情之一是我们有这种保持一致的压力，既要保持选择的一致，也要随着时间的推移保持一致。也就是说我们变得
completely entrenched or committed or stuck in the ways that we think about things and the frameworks that we use, in the schemas that we have in our mind. And essentially, it becomes the idea of, you know, if I have a hammer, everything is a nail. And so sometimes our expertise leads us to see the world as nails when in fact what we're looking at is bolts and screws rather than nails. I mean, this is the Polaride problem all over again, isn't it, which is Polaride had this business model, the Resident Blade model, and when digital cameras came along, they said, how do we adapt this new business, this new innovation to our existing strategy? That's right.
完全根深蒂固或承诺或陷入我们思考事物的方式以及我们使用的框架，在我们脑海中拥有的图式中。本质上，它变成了这样一种想法，你知道，如果我有一把锤子，一切都是钉子。所以有时我们的专业知识导致我们将世界视为钉子，而实际上我们看到的是螺栓和螺丝，而不是钉子。我的意思是，这又是宝丽来的问题，不是吗，也就是宝丽来有这种商业模式，“剃须刀与刀片”模式，当数码相机出现时，他们说，我们如何将这种新业务、这种新创新适应我们现有的战略？没错。
A square peg in a round hole, they had a round hole. It was incredibly successful for them. And when the square peg came along, they tried to figure out how do we make this new technology fit with our existing strategy because our strategy works for us right now. You've also found that binary thinking can affect what we pay attention to, what kind of information
方钉子插进圆孔里，他们有一个圆孔。这对他们来说非常成功。当方钉子出现时，他们试图弄清楚我们如何让这种新技术适应我们现有的战略，因为我们的战略现在对我们有效。你还发现二元思维会影响我们关注什么，我们寻找什么样的信息，
we seek out, what kind of information we ignore. I feel like in recent years we've seen the problems with binary thinking play out on a national and global scale during the run-up to the 2003 US invasion of Iraq for example American leaders frame the invasion as a binary choice either the US invade Iraq or the world was at risk for nuclear war Secretary of State Colin Powell spoke to the United Nations Security Council on February 5, 2003 about why inspectors had not found clear evidence of Iraq's weapons of mass destruction. All the inspectors to search the house of every government official, every path party member,
我们忽略什么样的信息。我觉得近年来我们已经看到二元思维的问题在国家和全球范围内上演，例如在2003年美国入侵伊拉克之前，美国领导人将入侵框架为二元选择，要么美国入侵伊拉克，要么世界面临核战争的风险。国务卿科林·鲍威尔于2003年2月5日在联合国安理会上谈到了为什么检查人员没有找到伊拉克大规模杀伤性武器的明确证据。让检查人员搜查每一位政府官员、每一位复兴党成员的房子，
and every scientist in the country to find the truth, to get the information they need to satisfy the demands of our council. Our sources tell us that in some cases, the hard drives of computers at the Iraqi weapons facilities, were replaced. Who took the hard drives? Where did they go? What's being hidden? Why? There's only one answer to the why, to deceive, to hide, to keep from the inspectors.
以及该国每一位科学家的房子，以找到真相，获得他们需要的信息来满足我们安理会的要求。我们的消息来源告诉我们，在某些情况下，伊拉克武器设施的计算机硬盘被更换了。谁拿走了硬盘？它们去了哪里？隐藏了什么？为什么？对于“为什么”只有一个答案，欺骗，隐藏，不让检查人员发现。
Numerous human... So he says there's only one answer to the why, to deceive, to hide, to keep from the inspectors. When I hear that now, at least with the benefit of hindsight, Wendy, that sounds to me like confirmation bias. It does. I'm so glad you raised this because I think this idea of binary thinking really intensifies as we move into higher levels of leadership
无数的人……所以他说对于“为什么”只有一个答案，欺骗，隐藏，不让检查人员发现。当我现在听到这个时，至少在事后诸葛亮的情况下，温迪，这听起来像是确认偏误。确实如此。我很高兴你提到了这一点，因为我认为这种二元思维的想法确实随着我们进入更高层次的领导力而加剧
and certainly into political leadership. And what we saw in that case was, do we go to war? Do we not go to war? And once we have decided we go to war, do we not go to war? And once we have decided to go to war, how do we then reinforce, create the confirmation bias that we have made the right decision not only for ourselves, but then also for the rest of the American public. And then, by the way, once the decision was made, then we see another bias, which is this bias of the escalation of commitment, which Barry Stah, who is a professor at Berkeley, had coined, which is that once we
当然也进入了政治领导力。我们在那个案例中看到的是，我们去打仗吗？我们不去打仗吗？一旦我们决定去打仗，我们不去打仗吗？一旦我们决定去打仗，我们如何然后强化，创造我们做出了正确决定的确认偏误，不仅是对我们自己，而且是对其余的美国公众。然后，顺便说一句，一旦决定做出，然后我们看到了另一个偏误，也就是这种承诺升级的偏误，这是伯克利教授巴里·斯托所创造的术语，即一旦我们
have committed to something, we double down and continue to commit to it over time. And we saw that bias then play out as well as we added troops over time to that war. You and others have called this effective binary thinking intensification or more colloquially as the character Morpheus might put it in the matrix, going down a rabbit hole. And I can sort of see that happening. Each step leads to the next step. And before you know it, you're 18 steps down the rabbit hole. And it's really hard to dig out because of the emotions that you've built around it,
对某事做出了承诺，我们就会加倍下注并随着时间的推移继续承诺它。我们也看到了那种偏误在随着时间的推移我们向那场战争增加军队时上演。你和其他人称这种有效的二元思维强化，或者更通俗地说，正如《黑客帝国》中的角色墨菲斯所说，掉进兔子洞。我可以看出这种情况正在发生。每一步都导致下一步。在你意识到之前，你已经掉进兔子洞18步了。而且真的很难挖出来，因为你围绕它建立的情感，
the supporting structures that you have around you all conspired to keep you down that rabbit hole to intensify the point of view. So it becomes really difficult emotionally and pragmatically to actually build out of it. Now, at some point, countries and companies and individuals make these binary choices and they go down one path and then eventually, reality eventually smacks them in the face and they realize they've made a terrible mistake.
你周围拥有的支撑结构都串通一气让你留在那个兔子洞里，以强化那个观点。所以要在情感上和务实上真正从中建立出来变得非常困难。现在，在某些时候，国家、公司和个人做出这些二元选择，他们走上一条路，然后最终，现实最终给了他们一记耳光，他们意识到他们犯了一个可怕的错误。
But sometimes, binary thinking produces yet another problem in situations like this and you call this the wrecking ball phenomenon. Can you explain what that is Wendy? Yes, so the wrecking ball is when once we've gone down a path and then the whole situation changes around us and we realize that we actually do need to change, we swing all the way to the other side. What we call as we over-correct. The problem with the wrecking ball is that it sort of gets rid of all of the good with the bad. You get rid of the problem with the wrecking ball is that it sort of gets rid of all of the good with the bad. You get rid of the baby with the bath water. You wreck everything that comes along in the way. I mean, I imagine that many of our listeners have experienced this kind of, you know,
但有时，二元思维在这样的情况下产生了另一个问题，你称之为“破坏球现象”。你能解释一下那是什么吗，温迪？是的，破坏球就是当我们走上一条路，然后整个情况在我们周围改变，我们意识到我们确实需要改变时，我们一直摆动到另一边。我们称之为过度矫正。破坏球的问题在于它有点像把好的和坏的一起扔掉。你把问题和破坏球一起扔掉，它有点像把好的和坏的一起扔掉。你把孩子和洗澡水一起倒掉了。你破坏了路上遇到的一切。我的意思是，我想我们的许多听众都经历过这种，你知道，
back and forth decision making, for example, and you know, efforts to maintain a healthy weight, for example, where people go on extreme diets and then swing all the way around and basically give up entirely. And in some ways, it's perhaps an individual version of what sometimes happens on a national or corporate scale. Yeah, I think that's right. I think that the dieting is a great example because we try and be so disciplined that eventually when we break down for a moment, instead of just breaking down and having the cookie that we want and then getting right back into the diet,
来回的决策，例如，你知道，努力保持健康的体重，例如，人们进行极端的节食，然后一直摆动到另一边，基本上完全放弃。在某些方面，这也许是国家或企业规模上发生的事情的个人版本。是的，我认为那是对的。我认为节食是一个很好的例子，因为我们试图变得如此自律，以至于最终当我们崩溃片刻时，与其只是崩溃并吃掉我们想要的饼干，然后立刻回到节食中，
we swing and we just let go of the whole thing. And then we swing back to over discipline. And we see the same thing with our work life sometimes. We get so invested in work until we get to a point of burnout. And then we totally let go until our email inbox becomes so full that we can't handle it anymore and so we sort of live in these over-emphasized swings. So you're the mother of three children, a 10-year-old and 16-year-old twins and
我们摆动并完全放手。然后我们摆动回到过度自律。我们在工作生活中有时也会看到同样的事情。我们对工作投入太多，直到我们达到倦怠点。然后我们完全放手，直到我们的电子邮件收件箱变得如此满，以至于我们无法再处理它，所以我们有点生活在这些过度强调的摆动中。所以你是三个孩子的母亲，一个10岁的孩子和16岁的双胞胎，
I understand that you know the wrecking wall phenomenon from your own parenting practices around sleep routines when they were small. We do. I mean, when you're trying to figure out how to parent, there are these really opposing approaches. The more disciplined and structured approach for your kids.
我理解你知道你自己的育儿实践中关于他们小时候睡眠习惯的破坏球现象。我们确实知道。我的意思是，当你试图弄清楚如何育儿时，有这些非常对立的方法。对你的孩子更自律和结构化的方法。
And then there's the more natural and approach in which your kids sort of engage in the way that they want. And sleep is like one of the first domains in which that kind of tension plays out. We started out to be very permissive with sleep and it was all great, but as you said, I have twins and their sleep schedules would be completely off. One would sleep at one time, one would sleep at the other time, and what we found was that it created an ensued chaos, and so we then said, okay, well we've got to do something to get them on to more of a schedule, and we went completely the other
然后还有更自然的方法，你的孩子以他们想要的方式参与。睡眠是那种紧张关系上演的第一个领域之一。我们开始时对睡眠非常宽容，一切都很好，但正如你所说，我有双胞胎，他们的睡眠时间表会完全错开。一个会在一个时间睡觉，一个会在另一个时间睡觉，我们发现它造成了随之而来的混乱，所以我们然后说，好吧，我们必须做点什么让他们进入更多的日程安排，我们完全走到了
way into that sort of incredibly disciplined sleep approach, and so we would close the door and let the baby cry themselves to sleep for a couple of nights, and we were all incredibly insane because of the amount of chaos that that ensued. And so, neither extreme approach worked particularly well for us. So, for the course of this episode, we've seen that it's very easy to fall into a pattern of thinking that's organized around this kind of binary either or choice. And once we do so, there's this whole cascade of problematic consequences that follows. When do I understand that you got a glimpse of another way of approaching hard questions? When you spend some time in Israel after college, tell me what happened while you were there,
那种极其自律的睡眠方法的另一边，所以我们会关上门，让婴儿哭着睡着几个晚上，因为随之而来的混乱，我们都变得极其疯狂。所以，没有一种极端的方法对我们特别有效。所以，在这一集的过程中，我们已经看到很容易陷入一种围绕这种“非此即彼”选择的思维模式。一旦我们这样做，随之而来的是一整串有问题的结果。温迪，我理解你瞥见了处理难题的另一种方式。当你在大学毕业后在以色列待了一段时间时，告诉我在那里发生了什么，
Wendy. I went there to go study Jewish texts being Jewish. I had always grown up culturally Jewish, but I was really intrigued and curious about the sort of texts and the background to the religions. So I went to go study in what's called the Yashiva, a liberal Yashiva that brought together both men and women, brought people from across the religious spectrum, given that I had not grown up particularly particularly religious. And we were studying Talmud, which is the classic Jewish text.
温迪。我去那里学习犹太文本，因为我是犹太人。我从小在文化上就是犹太人，但我对宗教的文本和背景非常感兴趣和好奇。所以我去学习所谓的“叶史瓦”，一所自由派的叶史瓦，它汇集了男人和女人，汇集了来自整个宗教光谱的人，鉴于我从小并不是特别宗教。我们正在学习《塔木德》，这是经典的犹太文本。
And the way that the Talmud works is that it is a compilation of ideas that are passed down from generation to generation orally until it was finally written down. And then all around, flanked around that is commentary from rabbis from across generations that are in conversation with one another across time with differing points of view.
《塔木德》的工作方式是，它是代代相传的想法的汇编，直到它最终被写下来。然后，围绕着它，两侧是来自各代拉比的评论，他们在时间上相互对话，有着不同的观点。
And one of the really intriguing pieces about studying Talmud is the extent to which there are discussions across scholars and rabbis about key issues in the Talmud, in which they are bringing up and raising conflicting ideas. And yet, most of the time, there's not a definitive answer to which one of these competing ideas wins out. In fact, at some point in the Talmud, there is a line that says these and these, meaning these two differing perspectives,
学习《塔木德》的一个非常有趣的片段是，学者和拉比之间在《塔木德》中关于关键问题的讨论程度，他们提出了相互冲突的想法。然而，大多数时候，对于这些相互竞争的想法中哪一个获胜并没有明确的答案。事实上，在《塔木德》的某个地方，有一行字说这些和这些，意思是这两个不同的观点，
that's what leads us to a deeper truth. Our binary, either-or approach to dilemmas, leads us to assume that if one choice is right, the other must be wrong. If one proposition is true, the other must be false. When these experience studying Jewish texts allowed her to see another possibility, that the opposite of a great truth can sometimes be another great truth. When we come back, how to escape from the shackles of either or thinking, without succumbing to the perils of indecision. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam.
这就是引导我们走向更深层真理的原因。我们对困境的二元、“非此即彼”的方法，导致我们假设如果一个选择是正确的，另一个一定是错误的。如果一个命题是真的，另一个一定是假的。温迪学习犹太文本的经历让她看到了另一种可能性，即一个伟大真理的对立面有时可以是另一个伟大的真理。当我们回来时，如何逃离“非此即彼”思维的枷锁，而不屈服于优柔寡断的危险。你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。
This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Wendy Smith is a psychologist at the University of Delaware. For years now, she has studied a series of cognitive traps that are created by dilemmas in our lives. When we confront what looks like a fork in the road, Wendy and her colleagues have found that our minds change in systematic and predictable ways. Many of these changes are not conducive to good decision-making. Wendy, the Jewish texts that you studied contained paradoxical insights? They contradicted each other, sometimes they contradicted themselves.
这是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。温迪·史密斯是特拉华大学的心理学家。多年来，她研究了我们生活中困境所创造的一系列认知陷阱。当我们面对看起来像十字路口的东西时，温迪和她的同事发现我们的思想以系统和可预测的方式改变。这些变化中的许多不利于良好的决策。温迪，你学习的犹太文本包含了悖论性的见解？它们相互矛盾，有时它们自相矛盾。
How did you take this insight into your own research? Well, what was fascinating to me was to think about this underlying notion of opposing ideas that were interdependent with one another. And I had that in the back of my mind as I came back to study organizations. And it was starting to study how organizations like Polaroid thought about these ideas of today and tomorrow or stability and change or their existing world and their innovative opportunities. And, you know, in some of the other pieces that I was studying, I was also exploring how organizations thought about things like social responsibility, or what we now think about
你是如何将这个见解带入你自己的研究中的？嗯，让我着迷的是思考这些相互依存的对立想法的潜在概念。当我回来研究组织时，我脑子里就有这个想法。它开始研究像宝丽来这样的组织是如何思考今天和明天，或稳定和变化，或他们现有的世界和他们的创新机会这些想法的。而且，你知道，在我研究的其他一些片段中，我也在探索组织是如何思考社会责任，或者我们现在思考的
is sustainability, which is this tension between a mission orientation or their markets, profits, or thinking about people and planet. And I was intrigued by the question of how about people and planet. And I was intrigued by the question of how profits and the could it coexist with the planet, how and a focus on the bottom line could coexist with a social mission. And it was there that I started to surface this notion of paradox and the relationship between these competing ideas. So you point out that paradoxes, in fact, are all around us. We just don't see them because we are so quick to try and reduce the world to binary choices.
可持续性，这是使命导向或他们的市场、利润，或思考人和地球之间的紧张关系。我被关于人和地球的问题所吸引。我被关于利润和地球如何共存的问题所吸引，底线关注如何与社会使命共存。正是在那里，我开始浮现出悖论的概念以及这些相互竞争的想法之间的关系。所以你指出，悖论实际上就在我们周围。我们只是看不到它们，因为我们太快地试图将世界简化为二元选择。
But in fact merely asking people to consider paradoxes makes them open to new possibilities. That's right. So if we think about the kinds of demands or kinds of challenges and dilemmas and tensions that we face, those really force on us, like you said, they sort of demand us, they expect of us, they lure us into making a choice. But if we pause and almost look underneath the hood or explore the structure of those choices, oftentimes what we see are these underlying paradoxeses where we see these dualities that are indeed in conflict with one another, and yet they're also interdependent. They define each other, they're interwoven with one another, and that persist over time. And so if we're looking at attention like studying how Polaroid is navigating its innovation, underlying that are these paradoxes of stability and change,
但事实上，仅仅要求人们考虑悖论就使他们对新的可能性持开放态度。没错。所以如果我们思考我们面临的需求或挑战、困境和紧张关系，那些确实强加给我们，就像你说的，它们有点要求我们，它们期待我们，它们引诱我们做出选择。但如果我们暂停并几乎看看引擎盖下面或探索这些选择的结构，通常我们看到的是这些潜在的悖论，在那里我们看到这些确实相互冲突的二元对立，然而它们也是相互依存的。它们定义彼此，它们相互交织，并且随着时间的推移而持续存在。所以如果我们正在看一种紧张关系，比如研究宝丽来如何导航其创新，其潜在的是稳定和变化的悖论，
of short-term and long-term, of existing world and the new world. And so it's those paradoxes that if we start to look at them, can introduce to us a very different way of thinking about the problem. One of the ideas you have on how people and organizations can do this is to do something that you call getting up on the balcony. What is this idea, Wendy? So getting up on the balcony is about reframing the way that I'm looking at the bigger picture. This is actually an idea that comes from Ron Hyphids, Marty Linsky, and their co-author,
短期和长期的，现有世界和新世界的悖论。所以正是那些悖论，如果我们开始观察它们，可以向我们介绍一种思考问题的非常不同的方式。你关于人们和组织如何做到这一点的一个想法是做一些你称之为“上阳台”的事情。这个想法是什么，温迪？所以“上阳台”是关于重构我观察大局的方式。这实际上是一个来自罗恩·海菲茨、马蒂·林斯基和他们的合著者，
Alexander Grasho. And it's their idea of adaptive leadership. What they say is that leaders have to effectively be in the fray, in the midst of the conversations, really thinking about the issues, which is being on the dance floor. But at the same time, they have to pause and take a look and be able to see the whole forest through the trees.
亚历山大·格拉肖的想法。这是他们关于适应性领导力的想法。他们说领导者必须有效地身处纷争之中，处于对话的中间，真正思考问题，这就是在舞池上。但与此同时，他们必须暂停并看一看，能够透过树木看到整个森林。
They have to be able to see the overarching picture and the differing perspectives. They have to take a broader and longer term perspective. And this is what they call getting up on the balcony to be able to let go of the immediacy of the arguments and be able to engage in the broader, more holistic point of view. You've written that one essential quality of paradox is that it accommodates multiple and even contradictory truths. I mean, that almost sounds like a parable. It does.
他们必须能够看到总体图景和不同的视角。他们必须采取更广泛和更长期的视角。这就是他们所说的“上阳台”，能够放下争论的即时性，能够参与更广泛、更全面的观点。你写道，悖论的一个基本品质是它容纳了多种甚至相互矛盾的真理。我的意思是，那听起来几乎像一个寓言。确实如此。
We often tell the Hindu parable of the blind people and the elephant. And the way that this parable goes is that a bunch of blind people came and approached an elephant and wanted to know what was before them. And so each of them touched a different part of the elephant. And by doing so, they had a different analysis or a different conclusion of what this was. So the person that was touching, the tusks thought that it was a spear and the person that was touching the trunk thought that it was a snake, and the person that was touching the legs thought that it was a tree stump. And so each of them really committed to
我们经常讲盲人摸象的印度寓言。这个寓言的方式是，一群盲人走近一头大象，想知道他们面前是什么。所以他们每个人都摸了大象的不同部位。通过这样做，他们对这是什么有了不同的分析或不同的结论。所以摸象牙的人认为它是一根长矛，摸象鼻子的人认为它是一条蛇，摸象腿的人认为它是一个树桩。所以他们每个人都真正致力于
what they had experienced and started to get into conflict with one another as they described what they experienced. It led to a tremendous amount of conflict. The aha here is that if each of them had paused to listen to one another, to understand what the others had seen and experienced, they would be able to get a better sense of the overall holistic picture that this was in fact an elephant
他们所经历的事情，并开始在描述各自经历时产生冲突。这导致了巨大的冲突。这里的顿悟在于，如果他们每个人都停下来倾听彼此，去理解其他人所见和所经历的一切，他们就能更好地把握整体的全貌，即这实际上是一头大象。
to put the different pieces together. And that's partially what we see with paradox, which is that we tend to go down, as we said, get stuck in the rabbit hole of one point of view, one perspective, our own expertise, our own identities, and become really stuck and committed to that, and not see the bigger picture to be able to put it together into something more holistic. You said a second ago that one of the qualities of paradoxes is that they are in fact not resolvable, that in fact the poles of a paradox are always going to persist and always generate tension.
将不同的部分拼凑在一起。这在某种程度上正是我们在悖论中看到的，也就是说，正如我们所说，我们倾向于陷入某种单一观点、单一视角、我们自己的专业知识、我们自己的身份认同的兔子洞中，变得非常固执和执着于此，而看不到更大的图景，无法将其拼凑成更全面的东西。你刚才说悖论的特质之一是它们实际上是无法解决的，事实上，悖论的两极总是会持续存在并不断产生张力。
And in fact this might be one of the reasons why many of us run away from paradoxes because they require us to sit with the discomfort of not being able to perfectly resolve the paradox in one direction or the other. So, when do you've come up with a few approaches to dilemmas that get us to see beyond the blinkers of binary thinking? And the first is something you call creative integration. Can you give me an example of this? Right, so a creative integration is kind of what we tend to think about when we think about both and thinking as an alternative to either or. It's the classic win-win, the find and ideal solution that accommodates both sides of competing
事实上，这可能是我们许多人逃避悖论的原因之一，因为它们要求我们忍受那种无法在某一个方向上完美解决悖论的不适感。那么，你提出了一些应对困境的方法，让我们能够超越二元思维的束缚。第一个是你所说的创造性整合。你能给我举个例子吗？好的，创造性整合就是当我们把“既要又要”思维作为“非此即彼”的替代方案时所想到的那种东西。这是经典的双赢，即找到一种能兼顾竞争双方需求的理想解决方案。
demands. We use this classic example of the muole because the muole is smarter than a donkey and faster than a horse. And we can think of a whole bunch of moments where we would see this kind of creative integration. In fact, there was a brilliant author and psychiatrist Albert Rothenberg, and he was really interested in understanding
我们使用骡子这个经典例子，因为骡子比驴聪明，比马跑得快。我们可以想到很多能看到这种创造性整合的时刻。事实上，有一位杰出的作家和精神病学家阿尔伯特·罗森伯格，他非常热衷于理解
how it was that geniuses came up with their best ideas. And what he found was that geniuses like Mozart and Picasso and Einstein and Virginia Woolf in her writing really came to these brilliant masterpieces by juxtaposing ideas and finding this creative integration between them. So, you know, for example, Einstein's theory of relativity emerged by asking how could an object be both at motion and at rest at the same time. For Picasso, it was how do you juxtapose dark and light within an image to create something more holistic? And then for Virginia Woolf, she plays with these these images the integration of life and death in some very powerful ways to bring out some really evocative emotions.
天才们是如何想出他们最好的点子的。他发现，像莫扎特、毕加索、爱因斯坦和弗吉尼亚·伍尔夫在她的写作中，确实是通过并置思想并在它们之间找到这种创造性整合，从而创作出这些辉煌杰作的。所以，你知道，例如，爱因斯坦的相对论就是通过思考一个物体如何能同时处于运动和静止状态而产生的。对于毕加索来说，是如何在图像中并置黑暗与光明以创造出更全面的东西？而对于弗吉尼亚·伍尔夫，她以一些非常有力量的方式运用了生命与死亡的整合这些意象，从而引发出一些非常令人回味的感触。
There's a second method to engage with paradox and you call it tightrope walking. What do you mean by this Wendy? In the very first research study that I ever did, I was studying how IBM was managing both its existing product and its innovation. And I went in thinking that there were going to be all of these brilliant mules, these creative integrations in which they found this moment that both the existing product and innovation could work beautifully together. And instead I saw something very different. What the most effective leaders were doing was that they were making these sort of subtle tweaks between how they would allocate their resources or how they would think about the structures of their organizations that would sometimes reinforce and benefit the existing
应对悖论的第二种方法，你称之为走钢丝。温迪，你这是什么意思？在我做的第一个研究中，我研究了IBM是如何同时管理其现有产品和创新的。我进去时以为会看到所有这些聪明的“骡子”，即那些创造性的整合，他们找到了一个让现有产品和创新都能完美协作的时刻。但我看到的却完全不同。最有效的领导者所做的是，他们在如何分配资源或如何思考组织结构方面进行了一些微妙的调整，这些调整有时会加强并造福于现有
products and sometimes reinforce and benefit the innovation. But they were making these tweaks in very subtle ways over time. And we call it tightrope walking because if you think about a tightrope walker, they are looking out to the future, focused on a goal and a point, but in order to get there, they're never completely balanced. They're always balancing. That is their sort of subtly shifting between left and right in order to get out to the future. I mean, in some ways, it's the very opposite of the wrecking ball, isn't it?
产品，有时会加强并造福于创新。但他们随着时间的推移，以非常微妙的方式进行这些调整。我们称之为走钢丝，因为如果你想象一个走钢丝的人，他们看向未来，专注于目标和某一点，但为了到达那里，他们从来不是完全平衡的。他们一直在保持平衡。这就是他们为了走向未来而在左右之间微妙地转换。我的意思是，在某些方面，这与破坏球正好相反，不是吗？
Because the wrecking ball doesn't make slight adjustments from left to right. It basically is swinging all the way from one end of the pendulum to the other. Whereas what this is suggesting is that you can actually make adjustments that are very small and by making a number of them, you can actually stay upright on the tightrope. That's right. If you go too far to the left or too far to the right, you fall off. And so that is the wrecking ball approach where you end up in this vicious cycle. This is actually a much more subtle approach. Wendy told me she practices a form of tightrope walking herself when she feels pulled into
因为破坏球不会在左右之间做微小的调整。它基本上是在钟摆的一端摆动到另一端。而这所暗示的是，你实际上可以做出非常小的调整，通过进行多次调整，你实际上可以保持在钢丝上直立。没错。如果你向左或向右走得太远，你就会掉下来。所以这就是破坏球的方法，最终会陷入恶性循环。这实际上是一种更微妙的方法。温迪告诉我，当她感到被拉向
directions. For example, she has to choose between a family reunion that often takes place in the United States over the July 4th holiday and an important academic conference in Europe that is scheduled at the same time of the year. That's a little bit more of a tightrope approach, which is the way that I can both and in that situation both be with my family and reinforce and support and deepen my connection to my colleagues and my work is that some years I make a choice to be with my family, some years I make a choice to be at my conference, and some years there might be this perfect
不同方向时，她自己也会练习一种走钢丝。例如，她必须在通常于7月4日假期在美国举行的家庭聚会和每年同一时间在欧洲举行的重要学术会议之间做出选择。这更像是一种走钢丝的方法，即在这种情况下，我如何能“既要又要”，既能与家人在一起，又能加强、支持并加深我与同事和工作的联系，那就是有些年份我选择与家人在一起，有些年份我选择参加会议，而有些年份可能会有这种完美的
both and, which is that the conference isn't exactly on July 4th, and I can be with my family and then go to the conference. But what it suggests is that part of the ways in which we can both-and is that we don't have to find the perfect both-and in every moment. We have to consider each choice individually. We can think about how the compilation or portfolio of choices over time allows us to commit to these two different demands or needs or goals that we have. It seems to me though, Wendy, you've made a really strong case for both and thinking, but I'm wondering, is there also room in this thesis
“既要又要”，即会议并不正好在7月4日，我可以先与家人在一起，然后再去参加会议。但这表明，我们能够“既要又要”的部分方式在于，我们不必在每一刻都找到完美的“既要又要”。我们必须单独考虑每一个选择。我们可以思考随着时间的推移，选择的组合或组合投资组合如何让我们能够致力于我们拥有的这两个不同的需求或目标。温迪，在我看来，你已经为“既要又要”思维提出了非常有力的论据，但我很好奇，在这个论点中是否还有空间
for the times in which we actually have to make a unitary decision? I can imagine there are times in the lives of individuals, of companies, of countries where in fact the right answer is not, how do we balance this multiplicity of options before us, but in fact to pick, you know, choice A or choice B? Shankar, I love that question. And in part, this helps us to differentiate between what's a dilemma and what's a paradox. And so what we would argue is that paradoxes persist over time and we want to accommodate them both. Dilemas are the dressing or the instantiations of particular paradoxes. And so what comes before us is a dilemma that forces us to make a choice.
留给那些我们实际上必须做出单一决策的时候？我可以想象，在个人、公司、国家的生活中，确实存在一些时候，正确的答案不是“我们如何平衡面前的多种选择”，而是“选择A还是选择B”？尚卡尔，我喜欢这个问题。在某种程度上，这有助于我们区分什么是困境，什么是悖论。我们认为，悖论会随着时间的推移而持续存在，我们希望两者兼顾。困境是特定悖论的表象或体现。所以摆在我们面前的是一个迫使我们做出选择的困境。
Am I going to go to war or not going to go to war? Am I going to go to my conference or stay with my family? Am I in this moment going to spend this hour doing work or am I going to go and help my kids with homework? And each of those requires an either or choice. What we would argue is that, again, if we pause and look at the paradoxes underneath, it will help us think about how we navigate those choices over time. So even once we go to war, we're still constantly in an ongoing conversation. Should we stay? Should we escalate our troops? How should we navigate that? And it's those possibilities, re we stay, should we escalate our troops, how should we navigate that? And it's those possibilities, re-thinking, being open to constantly seeing alternative
我是要开战还是不参战？我是要去参加会议还是留在家人身边？我此刻是要花这一小时工作，还是去帮孩子们做作业？每一个都需要一个“非此即彼”的选择。我们认为，同样，如果我们停下来看看底层的悖论，它将有助于我们思考如何随着时间的推移来驾驭这些选择。所以即使我们开战了，我们仍然不断地处于持续的对话中。我们应该留下吗？我们应该升级我们的部队吗？我们应该如何驾驭它？正是这些可能性，重新思考，对不断看到替代
perspectives that helps us to consider how we navigate those choices in an ongoing way over time. So when do we started this episode by talking about a company that faced a dilemma, the models and patterns that made Polaroid so successful in the past were getting in the way of its survival in the future. Now you and some collaborators have studied another well-known company that seemed headed for the same fate. Tell me the story of Lego.
视角保持开放，有助于我们考虑如何随着时间的推移以持续的方式驾驭这些选择。那么温迪，我们开始这一集时谈到了一家面临困境的公司，使宝丽来在过去如此成功的模式和范式正在阻碍其未来的生存。现在你和一些合作者研究了另一家似乎走向同样命运的知名公司。给我讲讲乐高的故事。
So Lego was a company that exactly like Polaroid was at the top of its market and then was a product of the way in which success can lead to failure. This is a company that was studied by my co-author, Mary Ann Lewis and her Danish collaborator, Lada Lusher. Lego was started in the 1930s, it was a family-owned business. Legel is here. Hey, kids! Eventually, they figured out this brilliant idea of the interlocking brick that became tremendous in the toy market. In fact, at some point, they controlled nearly 80% of the construction toy market globally. This young boy has such fun. We will play go one by one.
所以乐高是一家和宝丽来完全一样的公司，处于市场的顶端，然后是成功导致失败的产物。这是一家由我的合著者玛丽安·刘易斯和她的丹麦合作者拉达·卢舍尔研究的公司。乐高始于20世纪30年代，是一家家族企业。乐高在这里。嘿，孩子们！最终，他们想出了这个互锁积木的绝妙点子，在玩具市场上变得非常巨大。事实上，在某个时候，他们控制了全球近80%的拼搭玩具市场。这个小男孩玩得真开心。我们将一个接一个地玩乐高。
We will be next at a webtoot of a lane. This young boy's led Lego king. Lego, a whole new world to build. This young girl. Like Polaroid, Lego really resisted any kind of change in terms of its approach. And so we saw that kind of resistance in things like they had developed their interlocking brick in five colors, red, yellow, blue, black, and white, and it took them years to decide that they were going to add green to the mix. And there is this classic story
我们将成为车道上的网络足迹。这个小男孩领导乐高王国。乐高，一个全新的世界去建造。这个小女孩。像宝丽来一样，乐高确实抵制了其方法方面的任何改变。所以我们看到了那种抵制，比如他们开发了五种颜色的互锁积木，红色、黄色、蓝色、黑色和白色，他们花了几年时间才决定将绿色加入其中。而且有一个经典的故事
where in one of their meetings, George Lucas came into their senior leadership meeting and proposed the idea of a collaboration between Lego and Star Wars, and one of the vice presidents basically declared over my dead body will we ever introduce Star Wars to Lego. So real resistance to change. But then, like Polaroid, Lego started confronting a major disruption. Computer games were getting increasingly popular and starting to steal market share. Lego behaved exactly like Polaroid. First, they doubled down on their existing model. When that didn't work, they hit the panic
在他们的一次会议上，乔治·卢卡斯来到他们的高层领导会议上，提出了乐高与星球大战合作的想法，其中一位副总裁基本上宣称，除非我死了，否则我们永远不会把星球大战引入乐高。所以对改变有真正的抵制。但后来，像宝丽来一样，乐高开始面临重大的颠覆。电脑游戏越来越受欢迎，并开始抢占市场份额。乐高的表现和宝丽来一模一样。首先，他们加倍投入现有的模式。当这不起作用时，他们按下了恐慌
button. It started to spiral like Polaroid down this rabbit hole of committing to its existing approach and eventually realized that they were going to fail if they did. So Lego was a great example of what they did was that they over corrected. They started to say, okay, we need to innovate, we need to innovate now and we needed to innovate fast. And they started to produce all different kinds of sets that weren't just the classic interlocking
按钮。它开始像宝丽来一样陷入这种致力于现有方法的兔子洞，最终意识到如果他们这样做，他们就会失败。所以乐高是一个很好的例子，他们所做的是矫枉过正。他们开始说，好吧，我们需要创新，我们需要现在就创新，我们需要快速创新。他们开始生产各种各样的套装，而不仅仅是经典的互锁
brick, but it was all different kinds of sets that weren't just the classic interlocking brick, but it was all different kinds of pieces. Within seven years, they moved from something like 6,000 different types of pieces to 14,000. They moved into not just green, but 157 different colors and hues. It was at this time that they even moved out of the bricks. That's when they introduced new mini figures. They had about six different types of chefs. And each one of them just a little bit more nuanced than the other. That's when they introduced Lego land of the theme park.
积木，而是各种各样的套装，不仅仅是经典的互锁积木，而是各种各样的零件。在七年内，他们从大约6000种不同类型的零件增加到了14000种。他们不仅转向了绿色，还有157种不同的颜色和色调。正是在这个时候，他们甚至走出了积木。那时他们引入了新的小人仔。他们大约有六种不同类型的厨师。每一个都比另一个稍微细致一点。那时他们引入了乐高乐园主题公园。
And they start to co-brand with Star Wars and so many others. So they started to try all different kinds of things in order to keep up with the market. So they moved from a very conservative approach to try everything and anything possible. I mean it's almost the wrecking ball phenomenon writ large, right? You're throwing literally anything at the wall, seeing what will stick. I'm wondering how this sudden switch in the direction of excessive innovation, how did it affect the company and its balance sheet?
他们开始与星球大战和其他许多品牌进行联合品牌推广。所以他们开始尝试各种各样的事情以跟上市场。所以他们从一种非常保守的方法转向尝试一切可能的事情。我的意思是这几乎是破坏球现象的放大版，对吧？你实际上是在向墙上扔任何东西，看看什么能粘住。我想知道这种向过度创新的突然转变，是如何影响公司及其资产负债表的？
You know, it was this over correction, this wrecking ball that almost led them into bankruptcy. Because what they found was that revenues were going up, but costs were so significant, they had skyrocketed to such a degree that their profits were just declining. And they were in a really quick, vicious cycle. They were spiraling downward incredibly quickly. So, in 2003, the Lego Group announced the biggest loss in its history, and some wonder
你知道，正是这种矫枉过正，这种破坏球，几乎导致他们破产。因为他们发现收入在增加，但成本太高了，飙升到如此程度，以至于他们的利润在下降。他们陷入了一个非常快速的恶性循环。他们正在以令人难以置信的速度螺旋式下降。所以，在2003年，乐高集团宣布了其历史上最大的亏损，有些人怀疑
if the company was going to survive. A new leadership team was brought in. What happened? What did they do? What actions did they take? The new leadership team looked out and said, okay, well, we need innovation. We need new ideas, but not to this extreme. They started to think about how could we come up with some simple rules, some boundaries,
公司是否能生存下去。一个新的领导团队被引入。发生了什么？他们做了什么？他们采取了什么行动？新的领导团队放眼望去，说，好吧，我们需要创新。我们需要新的想法，但不要达到这种极端。他们开始思考我们如何能提出一些简单的规则，一些界限，
some guardrails that would allow us to innovate, but not go so far that we're going to fall over and that we're going to fail as a result. And so they then scaled back. They looked across all of their different pieces. They looked across all their different types and said, okay, what are we going to keep and what are we going to get rid of and became much more disciplined about their innovation so that they could reduce their costs while still maintaining this new and these new opportunities in the market. So we saw that Polaroid wasn't able to meet the
一些护栏，让我们能够创新，但又不会走得太远以至于跌倒，导致失败。所以他们随后缩减了规模。他们审视了所有不同的零件。他们审视了所有不同的类型，说，好吧，我们要保留什么，我们要放弃什么，并对他们的创新变得更加自律，这样他们就可以在降低成本的同时，保持这种新的和市场上的这些新机会。所以我们看到宝丽来无法应对
challenge, it eventually filed for bankruptcy, what became a FLEGO? up succeeding in fact and living in this ongoing tension. In fact in their 2020 annual report their group CEO said that they had hit a year of record profit, calling on this need to maintain a commitment to being both creative and disciplined over time. After nearly destroying the company with binary thinking, Lego changed its entire philosophy. Like the Jewish texts Wendy had read, the company began to realize that success was not about eliminating paradoxes, but living with them. This is what's so beautiful about Lego is that they have built this idea of paradox now, not only into how they think about innovating and how they approach their products and their market.
挑战，最终申请了破产，乐高变成了什么？事实上取得了成功，并生活在这种持续的张力中。事实上，在他们的2020年年度报告中，他们的集团首席执行官表示，他们创下了利润记录的一年，呼吁这种需要保持对随着时间的推移既有创造力又自律的承诺。在用二元思维几乎摧毁公司之后，乐高改变了其整个哲学。就像温迪读过的犹太文本一样，公司开始意识到成功不是关于消除悖论，而是与它们共存。这就是乐高如此美妙的地方，他们现在已经将这种悖论的理念，不仅融入到他们如何思考创新以及如何对待产品和市场的方式中。
They've built it into how they think about leadership, they've built it into how they think about the culture of the company. So, you know, they talk about the importance of being able to lead and be out in front, but also hold oneself back and enable space for other people. They talk about the importance of being able to trust one another, but also to verify, to be able to keep an eye on what's happening so that you are able to feel confident. They talked about, you know, an important one, they talk about being courageous and certain to be sure of yourself, but also have some humility and to be curious
他们将其融入到他们如何思考领导力，融入到他们如何思考公司文化中。所以，你知道，他们谈论能够领导并走在前面，但也能够克制自己并为他人留出空间的重要性。他们谈论能够互相信任，但也能够核实，能够留意正在发生的事情，以便你能够感到自信的重要性。他们谈论，你知道，一个重要的，他们谈论勇敢和确定，对自己有信心，但也保持谦逊和好奇
and open to new possibilities and wonder if there's other ways to do things. So these are really baked into how they talk about their culture, what they inculcate in the organization and what they hope and expect out of their people. How well have you come to practice these principles in your own life, Wendy? I love the word practice because indeed it's an ongoing practice. It's something that on one hand when I hear an either or question be asked, I have this immediate gut reaction to change the question from the either or to how can we do one and the other. And at the same time, I still find myself, I often find myself getting caught in a particular
并对新的可能性持开放态度，想知道是否有其他做事方式。所以这些确实融入了他们如何谈论他们的文化，他们在组织中灌输什么，以及他们对员工的希望和期望。温迪，你在自己的生活中实践这些原则做得如何？我喜欢“实践”这个词，因为这确实是一个持续的实践。一方面，当我听到有人问“非此即彼”的问题时，我有一种立即的直觉反应，要把问题从“非此即彼”改为“我们如何既做这个又做那个”。与此同时，我仍然发现自己，我经常发现自己陷入某种
point of view wanting to argue for it. And I learned a long time ago that I need to remind myself to stay quiet, to pause, to listen, to hear the differing ideas before I come to a conclusion. And so my reminder to myself often to do that is to go into a meeting, I will draw a little X on my hand and the X will say, when do you keep quiet? And the value of doing that is that I spend more time listening before I come to a point of view
观点，想要为它辩护。很久以前我就学会了，我需要提醒自己保持安静，停下来，倾听，在得出结论之前听听不同的想法。所以我经常提醒自己这样做的方法是去开会时，我会在手上画一个小X，X会说，温迪，保持安静。这样做的价值在于，我在得出观点之前花了更多时间倾听
so that I can engage with these different perspectives. I do think it's an ongoing practice and I think it's emotional, it is hard. And one thing that we talk about is it requires us to constantly recognize the discomfort of living in these opposing ideas and try and work through that to find comfort in that discomfort.
这样我就可以与这些不同的观点互动。我确实认为这是一个持续的实践，而且我认为这是情绪化的，这很难。我们谈论的一件事是，它要求我们不断认识到生活在这些对立思想中的不适感，并尝试通过它来在那种不适中找到舒适。
Wendy Smith is a professor of business at the University of Delaware. With her co-author, Marianne Lewis, she's the author of both and thinking, embracing creative tensions to solve your toughest problems. Wendy, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Shankar, it's been really fun to have this conversation. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarelle, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. For today's unsung hero, we turn the
温迪·史密斯是特拉华大学的商业教授。她与合著者玛丽安·刘易斯一起，是《既要又要思维：拥抱创造性张力以解决最棘手的问题》一书的作者。温迪，非常感谢你今天加入Hidden Brain。尚卡尔，进行这次谈话真的很有趣。Hidden Brain由Hidden Brain Media制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、安妮·墨菲·保罗、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·夸雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德威克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是Hidden Brain的执行编辑。对于今天的无名英雄，我们将
mic over to you, our listeners. This segment is brought to you by OnStar. OnStar advisors are now with you everywhere, on the app, in your car, and at home. Today's story comes from Walter Delgado. Walter grew up in El Salvador. When he was young, his mother moved to the United States to earn money for the family, so Walter lived with his grandparents. My mom one day called me and she said, do you want to come to the United States? And obviously I was 11 years, and I kept hearing good things about the United States. And I said, yes, when do I leave? The first part of the trip, we were traveling in buses.
麦克风交给你，我们的听众。本环节由OnStar为您呈现。OnStar顾问现在随时随地与您同在，在应用程序上，在您的车里，在家里。今天的故事来自沃尔特·德尔加多。沃尔特在萨尔瓦多长大。他小时候，母亲搬到美国为家庭赚钱，所以沃尔特和祖父母住在一起。有一天我妈妈打电话给我，她说，你想来美国吗？显然我当时11岁，我一直听到关于美国的好事。我说，是的，我什么时候走？旅程的第一部分，我们坐的是公共汽车。
It was all the way until we got to the Mexican border with the USA that that's when things got serious. And we were all in a warehouse. and border with the USA that that's when things got serious and we were all in a warehouse. And I'm talking about like 200, 300 people in a big warehouse. And one time they came and said, okay, we're ready and we're gonna walk through the desert
一直到我们到达墨西哥与美国的边境，事情才变得严重起来。我们都在一个仓库里。和美国的边境，那时事情变得严重了，我们都在一个仓库里。我说的是像200、300人在一个大仓库里。有一次他们来了说，好吧，我们准备好了，我们要穿过沙漠
an entire night. And that's when it hit me. I don't know what, wow. I was traveling with my grandfather, and I was 11, and he was old, so I was like, this is gonna be rough, and we would start walking, and I remember that I was wearing the worst shoes you can choose to walk in the desert.
整整一个晚上。那时我才意识到。我不知道什么，哇。我和我祖父一起旅行，我11岁，他年纪大了，所以我当时想，这会很艰难，我们会开始走路，我记得我穿的是在沙漠里走路最糟糕的鞋子。
I was wearing the worst, it was uncomfortable, rough. It was dark, and we were not prepared for those temperatures. I mean. I was wearing the words. It was uncomfortable, rough, it was dark and we were not prepared for those temperatures. I mean, again, we come from Central America over this tropical weather. Nobody was prepared. And the whole time we were cold, we were walking. I could hear woman crying and you know, like sometimes they're complaining of pain, their legs, and you know, heavy breathing, all those things are the most that I remember. I met Modesto alone the way. For the most part, he was quiet, slim, 5, 10.
我穿的是最糟糕的，很不舒服，很粗糙。天很黑，我们没有为那种温度做好准备。我的意思是。我穿的是最糟糕的。很不舒服，很粗糙，天很黑，我们没有为那种温度做好准备。我的意思是，再说一次，我们来自中美洲，那种热带天气。没有人做好准备。整个过程中我们都很冷，我们在走路。我能听到女人的哭声，你知道，有时她们抱怨疼痛，她们的腿，你知道，沉重的呼吸，所有这些都是我记得最清楚的事情。我在路上遇到了莫德斯托。在大多数情况下，他很安静，苗条，5英尺10英寸。
I remember we just had normal casual, small talk, where you from, all that. I didn't know that guy from back home. I didn't know anything about him. That's when after six hours of walking and my feet started giving out. Like I was tired and I just remember that I told him, and hey man, I can't, I can't my legs and he just can't pull me up, you know, put me on his bag and started walking. And he told me, don't worry, we almost there,
我记得我们只是进行了正常的随意闲聊，你从哪里来，所有这些。我不知道那个家伙来自家乡。我对他一无所知。就在走了六个小时后，我的脚开始支撑不住了。就像我很累，我只记得我告诉他，嘿伙计，我不能，我不能我的腿，他只是把我拉起来，你知道，把我放在他的背上，开始走路。他告诉我，别担心，我们快到了，
we're gonna make it. I'm gonna make sure you're gonna make it. And those are the words that he kept saying, you know, we're going to make it. We're going to make it. Of course, you get those thoughts, you know, like, I'm not going to be left behind. I mean, there's so many people that they don't make in that journey. So, you know, we just met on the trip and to have the goodness, the willingness to carry someone, I must have been at least 90 pounds, probably 100 pounds.
我们会成功的。我会确保你会成功的。这些就是他一直说的话，你知道，我们会成功的。我们会成功的。当然，你会产生那些想法，你知道，比如，我不会被抛在后面。我的意思是，有那么多人没有完成那段旅程。所以，你知道，我们只是在旅途中相遇，拥有背负某人的善良和意愿，我当时肯定至少有90磅，可能100磅。
He easily probably carried me for two to three hours. I am not exaggerating. And I should imagine, you know, he must have been tired too, the whole time. It just blows my mind. And it's one of those defining moments in my life where it gives me hope. And I can see that human beings can be a channe-le of goodness to the world. It takes me back to that that we can be good
他很轻松地可能背了我两到三个小时。我没有夸张。我想象，你知道，他肯定也很累，整个过程。这让我感到震惊。这是我生命中那些决定性的时刻之一，它给了我希望。我可以看到人类可以是世界上善良的渠道。这让我想起我们可以善良
and we can do good to others. You never know how you're going to impact other people. Small gestures can go a long way. Eventually, Walter and his grandfather made it to their destination. He became a U.S. citizen, went to college, and has a good career. For all of that, he credits Modesto. Everything that I have now, everything that I accomplish now, it takes me back to that moment. I can make more money, I can live comfortably, I have a good life now. Thank God, and thanks to Modesto, because he was the one that made it all possible.
我们可以对他人行善。你永远不知道你将如何影响他人。小的姿态可以走很远。最终，沃尔特和他的祖父到达了目的地。他成为了美国公民，上了大学，并拥有了很好的职业。对于这一切，他归功于莫德斯托。我现在拥有的一切，我现在完成的一切，都让我想起那一刻。我可以赚更多的钱，我可以舒适地生活，我现在过着美好的生活。感谢上帝，感谢莫德斯托，因为是他让这一切成为可能。
possible. Walter Delgado lives in Houston. This segment was brought to you by OnStar. OnStar believes everyone has the right to feel safe everywhere. That's why their emergency advisors are now available to help not only in the car but wherever you are. On your phone, in your car, and at home. Onstar, be safe out there. If you like this episode and would like us to produce more shows like this, please consider supporting our work. Go to support.hiddenbrain.org. Again, if you find our work to be useful in your life, do your part to help us thrive. Go to support.hiddenbrain.org. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
可能。沃尔特·德尔加多住在休斯顿。本环节由OnStar为您呈现。OnStar相信每个人都有权在任何地方感到安全。这就是为什么他们的紧急顾问现在不仅可以在车里，而且无论你在哪里都可以提供帮助。在你的手机上，在你的车里，在家里。Onstar，在外注意安全。如果你喜欢这一集，并希望我们制作更多这样的节目，请考虑支持我们的工作。前往support.hiddenbrain.org。再次，如果你发现我们的工作对你的生活有用，尽你的一份力量帮助我们茁壮成长。前往support.hiddenbrain.org。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。很快再见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。